Carla Hayden made history when she was
confirmed as a fourteenth librarian of
Congress go you morning last week
becoming the first woman and the first
black person to ever hold this position
go you again
Hayden is responsible for overseeing the
world's largest library there's more
than one hundred and sixty two million
pieces that's with an M in the
collection the new librarian of Congress
Carla Hayden joins us at the table good
morning - good morning
this is so exciting I was here being the
library ball no let's start with you
Carly because how did you get on the
president's radar screen how do they
know about you actually I was a part of
a group of people that the
administration was contacting to consult
about the opportunities at the Library
of Congress so you were giving advice I
was given quite a bit of advice did you
say Carla Hayden would be perfect no no
and I I really had a an idea that this
could be an opportunity to open up what
I consider a treasure chest for so many
people and I talked about that a hundred
and sixty two million items people don't
even know what's in the Library of
Congress but yet you said you had to
think about it when you were off I did
have to think about it because of the
tables kind of turned in and I was asked
are would you consider being a candidate
and I did sit back because I had been in
public service in a public library in
Baltimore doing so many things directly
with people and I had to think how can I
translate from going to a community
serving a community to the country it is
one of the most beautiful buildings I
think in Washington DC yes it's so
beautiful and I know the bookshelves
have on 840 miles worth of books and
documents what have you uncovered since
you've been there well that actually
takes you from Washington DC all the way
to Iowa
oh right to the edge of Iowa I've
already seen Abraham Lincoln's life mask
not a deaf mess the contents of his
pocket the night he was assassinated
I've seen papers from Rosa Parks about
Rosa let me tell you that we had to have
her courier to sleep overnight
with those documents because they're so
precious and they barely leave like a
woman couldn't even leave the room she
had to have room so this letter we're
looking at this is your letter she this
was about six months after she refused
to give up her seat and she was invited
to New York and she said I have had
quite a time a stay here in New York she
had dinner with mr. and mrs. Thurgood
Marshall she met Eleanor Roosevelt she
heard as she said in a postscript I
heard dr. King speak at Madison Square
Garden and Alexander Hamilton wrote a
letter to his wife alive well now that
was something so the next letter that we
and this one she really the lady who
brought it up actually barely could
sleep she said knowing that that was it
this was the letter that he wrote to his
wife a few days before what he called
the interview and he really didn't want
to go to that duel the duel no he didn't
want to but he said honor he had to go
but in art isn't this so rare because
weren't most of the letters to Eliza
burned Eliza burning them after yes the
affair but the Reynolds pamphlet yeah
well this was later yeah things were
better yeah were they better come they
were better and these are the types of
things that people could really examine
and so what I'm excited about is putting
a lot of these things online so the kids
are home in access then you can live
your summers wouldn't that be something
yes oh yeah I have a few years to work
with a crackerjack staff you seem to be
a different kind of librarian you know
yes most people think of librarians no
disrespect they're a little prudish
they're a little uptight they're a
little stuffy they were comfortable
shoes well I didn't have one
contribution and you know you want to
change the whole thing because when
people think about librarians you know
in commercials if you want to show that
something is exciting
you show a library and she takes a bit
of candy and she goes wild
right so she takes off her glasses
because you know it must be good if a
librarian can go wild
like this movie yes oh it's a wonderful
life what's the last thing that you see
fate worse than death she's coming out
of the library at the end right yeah so
we want to make sure that history is fun
and people see the profession as
something that is desirable and let
people make their own history libraries
getting the support that they need I
mean I remember I grew up in Texas and
my mom would always take us to the
library to read books and also because
the air conditioning worked in Texas it
was good to be in the cool library but
our library is getting the same support
that they once had more people are
coming into libraries than ever before
okay we're doing all types of things
they're getting health information
they're coming in and I think there's an
awareness that a library is still a
place that means so much to the
community so they are getting with us
but they have to now you learn
technology in order yes access it's not
right and so that support is coming it's
coming
so when we think about the Library of
Congress I am the first librarian to
tweet since my swearing-in I have 10,000
followers so as I discover here have a
good Thomas Jefferson okay let me ask
you about Thomas gesture we gotta go was
he really connected to the library yes
yes his personal library is actually
what helped started thank you see how
exciting is getting and I want everybody
to do it thank you we're gonna come
visit okay thank you so much